you know what we're great partners i  think the episode and this is not a  there's a high five happening here for  the listeners  really that was bad  that's not the high five of a best  friend uh  for the people who are still listening  they finally connected on the high five  speaking of high fives can we just talk  for a second about caitlyn's high five  that's what i was trying to emulate  there she's got a wicked one where she's  so caitlyn's skateboarding she has a  little pop in it doesn't she you're  getting ready to go for it and she just  whacks your hand and i would talk to her  about it and be like that's not how you  high five she's like yeah it is you you  yeah you slap she puts an extra she puts  an extra pop in it yeah like a cobra  like that's striking yeah yeah she he's  got dog good one witch  nice let's roll i'm gonna get some beers